maryse plante à bonjour bonjour monsieur
car oui bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique la première etc guillierme en
lice puritani spirit qui nous reçoivent
oui puisque vous êtes candidate à
l'élection municipale pour le
saint-esprit
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé pour vous
présenter pour les élections de mars
prochain
alors je vais commencer par dire que
c'est par amour parce que j'aime ma
commune et j'aime les spiritains j'ai un
passé associatif depuis mon adolescence
je suis dans le milieu associatif
même si comparaison n'est pas raison une
ville n'est pas une association n'est
pas le quartier puisque c'est une
association de quartier mais je pour moi
c'est un tremplin
c'est une expérience parce que il faut
animer le quartier le quartier animé et
en même temps la ville en bénéficient
lorsque le quartier galles organis le
frugal de reagan mais bon nombre de
spirit et mêmes de martinique et j'ai
envie de dire participe à de différentes
manifestations
pour exemple c'est noël les je me rend
compte alors l'occasion de noël a et b
movado le 7 décembre sortie de noël
akchoté nouvelle régal moment de partage
où on se retrouve en toute convivialité
donc ce que vous voulez peut-être
transplantés au niveau de la
municipalité au général c'est ce que
vous faisiez déjà dans dans votre
quartier c'est ça un petit peu
a oui en partie en partant évidemment
mais je veux dire vous voulez vous
inspire et peut-être de ce travail
associatif fait au niveau de ce quartier
régal légal finalement l'appliquer au
saint-esprit mes besoins d'échelle a plu
à la voilà c'est ce serait ça c'est un
peu votre objectif pas uniquement parce
que c'est vrai que c'est des filles est
une ville enclavée
il manque d'attractivité et on avait
espéré effectivement que la ville serait
redynamiser une année au lien donc
cohésion spiritaines où j'ai l'honneur
de conduire la liste
notre ambition en toute cohésion c'est
faire revivre notre commune parce que
nous avons un patrimoine culturel
architectural et environnemental
nous avons déjà le nom nous avons déjà
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut maintenant
c'est optimiser optimisé redynamiser
alors si vous êtes mère alors vous avez
déjà dévoilé deux trois choses mais on
va quand même posé la question si vous
êtes élu maire maryse plante un ce sera
quoi votre dossier prioritaire
alors j'ai envie de dire que ce sera une
globalité
parce que comme je viens de le dire la
globalité on va y arriver parce que je
vous demandais quel est l'enjeu pour
vous pour la commune mais vous n'avez
pas une préoccupation particulière vous
avez à dire une extrême urgence un
dossier qui clope et jeté une urgence
plus que les autres alors tout est
important mais messi l'hôpital
c'est pas la commune la commune c'est le
terek elle met à disposition mais une
priorité quand même c'est la santé
c'est un hôpital de proximité où nous
avons un service d'addiction nous avons
un service de faits de vie de personnes
en fait de vie où les personnes ont
besoin d'être accompagnés jusqu'à
l'automne il souffre
nous avons la radiologie on peut faire
des analyses nous avons des personnes
âgées qui n'ont pas de moyen de
locomotion donc l'hôpital
il va falloir même si je le pouvais sans
quoi le même si je le précise
c'est pas la commune la commune doit
mettre le tir et donc il va falloir
qu'on se donne les moyens pour trouver
ceux tirés pour que l'hôpital reste au
cet esprit et pour conclure donc en
quelques mots qu'elle est mais oui quel
est l'enjeu qui elle est qu'est-ce qui
va se jouer là en mars pour pour
saint-esprit et ses habitants selon vous
nos fondamentales 1 de forme d'anneau de
fondamental ne sera pas du béton un pour
moi c'est pas le béton
je pense qu'il faut mettre l'humain au
centre et les remontées déjà tiré parce
que moi je fais du tir et je fais du
porte-à-porte
c'est le mode the proximity un maire est
un élu de proximité si ou lé travail ma
commune
séoul est au devant des besoins des
populations faut qu on dit en population
et nous il ya un maire qui il existe au
niveau proximité je précise au niveau
proximité donc il faut remettre
l'éducation avec majuscule au coeur des
choses s'occuper des spiritains prendre
en compte leurs doléances
travailler avec eux mais ne pas
travailler pour eux parce que je crois
que c'est fini l'époque où le maire
arrive avec son équipe et puis je dis
n'importe quoi en faire un bâtiment
il faut arrêter le bétonnage à tout va
il en faut
pas à tout va et comme je vous ai dit
précédemment nous avons aussi des fruits
jack roy rendent notre ville
accueillante agréable merci maryse
plante 1